I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense most people by now you know know
Colin Kaepernick is and know about the
you know his protests during the
national anthem this protest is about
police brutality and social injustice is
the best way to put it and I guess it
was it was August or September August
2016 so we're right right before the
election so it's very tumultuous time
you know with Trump versus Hillary
Clinton in line right this whole you got
to be on one team or the other and
everyone's like we're already dividing
like crazy oh and you know it's it's
it's frustrating especially I think as a
as a war fighter because you're fighting
for everybody moralizing to a society
yeah no more reasons to divide yeah it
is it's it's really frustrating and so
amidst that you know call and start
sitting on the bench during the anthem
and it's like huge uproar it blew up
even more than I think he was prepared
for and expected it to and I wrote this
up an open letter that week to to the
army times because I'd been reached out
to my like Fox News CNN MSNBC all the
big publications but I knew if I do
something because they knew you were in
the military because you were standing
next oh no I had been the military
because I played for the Seahawks a year
before okay so it was like oh this guy
served our country and also played
football so we must be the expert on
this the end of me what you should do or
whatever you know but yeah it was really
what you think and I didn't want to
really say because I was like it first
of all it doesn't matter a ton what I
think but and also if I if I take an
opinion or a stance it's just gonna
cause more issue it's gonna cause more
division but even if I go on a certain
Network because of what that networks
sort of the agendas they push sure
because they all do have yeah it'll put
me in like us everyone will assume I
believe all these yeah you're on CNN
yeah you're one way if you're on Fox or
another exactly I'm like I'm not either
those things like a some things I like
on this sides and things I like on that
side
yes I am and so I wrote for the army
time murder for the army times because
now that many people read the army time
first of all but second of all it's it's
not political at all like it's just you
know it's for the military whatever and
they posted it the next day and a ton of
sports journalists started sharing it so
it went like crazy viral and Colin ended
up reaching out I was about to go on the
first interview I was gonna do on TV was
for NFL Network because it was also like
our it's a sports channel it's gonna be
less political and I knew the people
there I felt more comfortable and so I'm
like in the green room and Colin's
publicist called me and said hey cones
at practice right now they're playing
their last preseason game tomorrow he's
starting it's down in San Diego is there
any way you'd be willing to go down
there and meet with him before they gave
he really wants to talk to you and I was
like sure so I go down there I'm finding
out as I head down it's like Military
Appreciation Night like the Navy SEALs
are gonna do a flyover and jump into the
stadium and like it's San Diego it's a
very military town yeah oh boy you know
this is gonna be big so I went down met
him in the lobby of the team hotel and
we talked for a couple of hours and just
like you mentioned a second ago like we
had so much more income and then we had
different and like we you know disagreed
on a few things but I agreed with a lot
of what he had to say like where it's
coming from as far as like yeah I want
to see things improve I don't want to
see you know any cops doing that I know
and he acknowledged to you like most of
them are really good people who wouldn't
stand for fairness exactly exactly
and so it was it was really just like
that was the conversation and and and if
by the end of it he was just like well
do you think there's another thing
something else I could do or another way
of demonstrating you know cuz I'm not
gonna stand during the anthem I've
already vowed to not and I don't want to
break that until I feel like things are
moving in the right direction and
changes are happening and I was like I
mean that's a tough question because no
matter what you do you're gonna get
criticized no there's just no there's no
perfect protests or whatever it's
supposed to be uncomfortably right it's
messy I mean it's like no no there's
always paying for girl
so you know the pain is like this is
uncomfortable for people right exactly
and I said but I would offer you this I
think it's important right now you're
sitting on the bench sort of isolated
from your team I think it would look
good if you were at least alongside your
teammates whatever you're doing because
there they don't all agree with you a
lot of them do but you're a quarterback
you're a leader of the team and I just
think you know being alongside that sort
of put you on an equal playing field and
whether that's just optically or for
them to like feel like all right it's
not making it about me I'm not making it
about me I'm doing this with my with my
guys and you know and they may not agree
but I think they would respect you more
if if you did that and he said he agreed
to that and and then I said so if you're
not gonna stand like what are you gonna
do because everything's I don't think
sitting on the field was a good idea and
he was like no I don't think so either
and I said what if you you know what if
you took a knee instead I said as far as
I know
kneeling has never really been seen as I
could disrespectful act in the history
of mankind and it's like people please
no but like written part yeah he sat for
two games before that and it was already
national news at that yeah so I thought
it was this I thought it was a good
adjustment honestly you know I thought
it was like at least he was willing to
listen and yeah and and and move in that
way I think that that story definitely
got lost and part of that was maybe I'm
callin for not you know talking about it
like why he decided to do that instead
but it is what it is and it was bizarre
cuz I mean that night you know that the
the team invited me to come down the
field and you don't stand with him he
had next to him I don't think I told him
I was gonna stand but I would you know
if he was willing to do that I would
stand next to him and in the you know
there's booze coming from the crowd
during the anthem and the Africans being
sung by an African American Navy
oh it was just interesting it was crazy
you